I was using a glutathione supplement in coffee enemas before I got a diagnosis of cancer.
Is it possible that glutathione caused my cancer? I have been sugar and grade-free for 20 years,
also totally organic diet for 40 years, and keto low carb diet with consistency daily fasting.
Can glutathione cause cancer? Well, for most people who don't understand the connection that
would be culture intuitive, glutathione is an antioxidant, glutathione helps prevent cancer,
because most cancers are caused from some sort of toxin or oxidizing agent that's getting
inside the cell and damaging the nucleus. So remember, cancer is a cell that, you know,
something got inside that cell and damaged the nucleus. So the nucleus is now in a state
of rapid replication. That's what the definition of cancer is, and it's replicated cells that are
in a state of replication. Now, the reason why this person asked about glutathione and cancer is
that I am one of those doctors who advocates against using glutathione. Once a person has a
diagnosis of cancer and the reason why I would say glutathione is culture contradictive
for a person with cancer diagnosis is that cancer cells, because they're already rapidly replicated,
already producing a lot of oxidative stress. So they're at that dear lethal dose of oxidative stress,
and by using glutathione, which is an antioxidant, you're basically helping to keep a cancer cell alive.
Now, I would not say that glutathione causes cancer. So, the answer to this person's question is
impossible that using glutathione in my coffee enemas before my cancer diagnosis would be a cause
of my cancer. I would say absolutely not. Glutathione is something that I would recommend somebody who
knows. They do not have a diagnosis of cancer. We are exposed to oxidizing agents, you know, at a rate
that is maybe a hundred times greater than our ancestors, and we need support for glutathione.
Glutathione is your main intracellular antioxidant. It's helping get rid of those damaging reactive
oxygen and reactive nitrogen species that develop in the presence of both pathogens, developing
that our body and in the presence of toxic chemical toxins. So, using glutathione helps decrease
the chance of a person getting cancer. But however, once you have cancer, you could actually be
helping the cancer stay alive. So, if you have a diagnosis of cancer, then many of the treatments
certainly standards of care treatment, chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, and it works to kill cancer
because cancer cells get a state of rapid replication, are producing a lot more reactive
oxygen species. They're at a state nearer, a lethal dose of oxidation, and you're giving an extra
little boost of oxidation, a chemotherapy, you can tell to kill the cancer. So, that's why cancer
cells die first with chemotherapy, chemotherapy can damage other cells, though, that's the negative
of it. But cancer cells are nearer, they're lethal dose of oxidative stress already, so giving them
a little more oxidative stress will help kill cancer cells. So, I wouldn't use glutathione
once you have cancer, but it certainly is not a cause of cancer.